The Rainbow six siege open beta launches
tomorrow at seven a.m. PST but it won't
be the same resolution on both
current-gen consoles yes this is
something people are still talking about
Ubisoft confirmed the open beta will run
at 1080p on ps4 and 900 p on xbox one
that's the same resolution as the
previous stage closed beta but you be of
said that the final performance could
still be better depending on how the
team's optimization efforts unfold you'd
be explained we're still looking to push
the hardware as much as possible in
order to deliver a quality experience
for players and we'll be able to share
more about the final resolution once
we're closer to release date the PC
resolution will vary between 720 and
1080 p depending on your setup the beta
which includes 14 operators 3 maps and
three game modes will run up until the
29th of November let me know if you're
planning to spend time with this one
when it lands tomorrow for all things
Rainbow six and everything else the
masses in gaming stay tuned at gamespot
you